il augmente ses expositions se
retrouvent aujourd'hui pour une vidéo un
peu spécial puisqu'il s'agit
effectivement de la clause spéciale 20
mille abonnés alors je remercie vraiment
tous et tous pour votre soutien je
pensais vraiment pas en arriver là quand
j'ai commencé sur youtube et j'ai décidé
les annotations vont apparaître alors
les vidéos
abonné il s'agit de tuer le sniper on a
droit à un concept très fun contre
plaindre youtuber connus ou alors qu'une
invitation l'apparition chacun nos maya
vous avez juste à cliquer sur la vidéo
nous tuera le nom à cannes youtuber
j'affronte fait partie des gens il
n'avait plus qu'à cliquer à cordes
appuyé sur mon ventre casque merci à
vous oui ça ira bon vieux airs [ __ ]
vous ne vous êtes pas les fics cet homme
est un taliban qui joue alice box
papa
les mecs vous avez le mot de la fin
commercial vingt mille abonnés
la zone 20 kg